for the first time jurors in the murder
trial of a white former Dallas police
officer who shot and killed her black
neighbor saw a video from the scene the
graphic new body cam and graphic is the
word this footage shows a chaotic
moments after amber Geiger killed both
from John in his own home she claims she
mistakenly thought he was in her
apartment
Omar Villafranca is at the courthouse in
Dallas Omar what did this testimony
reveal that video was very tough to
watch we learned the results of Geiger's
blood tests she did not have drugs or
alcohol in her system at the time of the
shooting the jury also saw a body cam
video of first responding officers and
it showed Geiger just moments after the
shooting and both of John's final
moments alive former Dallas police
officer amber Geiger appears frantic in
this body cam video she told
investigators she mistook 26-year old
both of John for a burglar in her
apartment when she opened fire moments
later you can see one of the officers
begin CPR on John for seven minutes
who is face-up on the floor bleeding
from a gunshot wound paramedics arrived
about five minutes later as John is
being wheeled out of the building
surveillance video shows Geiger who was
waiting in a squad car hugging and being
comforted by fellow officers in the
courtroom John's neighbor Joshua Brown
said he was heading back to his
apartment when he heard the interaction
between Geiger and John followed by two
gunshots
that's not what we heard no later Brown
became emotional talking about what it
was like living across from Jean
yesterday's testimony also cleared up
some speculation on how Geiger got into
John's apartment a video was shown that
showed her ki did not work in John's
door but investigators pointed out his
door did not latch properly and in fact
was slightly open there was no signs of
forced entry testimony resumes later on
this morning Anthony all right Omar
thank you